wenn Fluglehrer in der Fliegerschule in
Zeltweg und bei der Airpower wäre mit
der 40 im Großverband für die
Fliegerschule fliegen die Fliegerschule
setzt zwei fliegertypen für die
Schulungen die zum einen die der 40 auf
der finden auch die militärischen
fliegerischen Auswahlverfahren statt
das eignet sich dafür gut weil der
Flieger sehr gutmütig ist und nicht so
leistungsstark ist somit ist es zum
beginnen für die Fliegerei einen sehr
gutes Flugzeug die weitere fliegerische
Grundschulung findet auf der bc7 statt
die PC-7 wird in der Fliegerschule für
die militärisch fliegerische
Grundschulung eingesetzt da lernen die
Piloten des fliegerische Handwerk nach
Sichtflugregeln nach Nachtsicht
flugregeln und es wird dann auch in der
fortgeschrittenen Ausbildung eingesetzt
der Flieger eignet sich für Kunstflug
und ist leistungsstärker als die der 40
das Flugzeug PC-7 eignet sich auch für
die Schulung sehr gut weil die sind dann
im Cockpit Anordnung ist das heißt der
Flugschüler sitzt in der Mitte und der
Flugjahr kann von hinten sämtliche
Tätigkeiten des Flugschülers überwachen
die Flugeigenschaften der der 40 sind
für einen Flugschüler sehr gut geeignet
weil sich der Flieger im Grenzbereich
sehr gutmütig verhält und sich kritische
Flug Zustände gut bereinigen lassen und
der Flieger wie gesagt nicht zu
leistungsstark ist und somit für eine
Flugschüler leicht zu erlernen ist der
Ausbildung zum Militärpiloten beginnt im
Heeresspital in Wien mit den
medizinischen psychologischen
eignungsfeststellungen wenn diese
positiv absolviert wurden findet die
praktische fliegerische
eignungfeststellung in Zeltweg statt auf
der TA 40 wenn diese positiv
abgeschlossen wurde beginnt die
militärische Grundschulung auf der PC-7
in Zeltweg diese dauert ca 11 Monate